2008 : Le commencement.
Ça a commencé avec une idée : "Et si on faisait un film Deadpool ?"
On était peu nombreux à l'époque
et en y repensant, nous ne savions pas quelle ampleur ça allait prendre.
Tellement naïfs ! Et pourtant, la dynamique était lancée.
2009 : Deadpool apparaît dans X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
Oui alors ça, c'était pas du tout ce qu'on avait en tête...
2011 : Ryan Reynolds joue dans Green Lantern
Non, ça n'a pas aidé non plus...
2011-2014 : la Fox refuse Deadpool
C'était même un vrai NON pour être honnête. Nous avons finalement arrêté de demander.
2015 : Des séquences tests de Deadpool fuitent sur Internet
Nous ne savons toujours pas comment c'est arrivé,
mais je vous promet...
Que j'enquête dessus.
2016 : Sortie de Deadpool.
Quand le projet a été accepté par le studio, je me suis fait un énorme rail de coke
Du coup, 2016 a été un peu brumeux pour moi.
Mais on m'a dit que le film avait bien marché, donc bon.
2018 : Sortie de Deadpool 2
10 ans là dessus !
La Phase 1 a dépassé nos espérances les plus folles.
Si vous m'aviez dit à l'époque qu'un seul film engendrerait un univers étendu de 2 films
j'aurai dit que vous étiez fou.
Et pourtant nous y sommes !
Avec de vrais acteurs,
un budget effet spéciaux serré,
et plusieurs X-Men de seconde zone.
Aucun des plus connus.
On doit bien garder quelque chose pour la Phase 2...